the immigration site to move to Canada
crashed do you think people are gonna
really move to Canada you think so many
people here the rents too high and all
that just thin it out give us a little
negotiating thing and then what's gonna
be funny up there it's not gonna be
Michael Morris Canada what he said
though you keep your doors unlocked and
everybody's drinking syrup and it yeah
he did he didn't say everyone's drinking
zero-crossing everybody of color that
tried to make it playing hockey up there
listen to the stories they have you and
Alabama know those are still white
people up there yes because they're on
the other side of the invisible line
doesn't mean that they're not gonna act
like white people yeah so you're not a
big fan of Canada is what you're saying
no I love Canada but I don't go up there
with like this starry look in my eyes
like everyone's gonna be riding around
on mooses right it's just like these
people they're human beings they're
selfish they're into what they want yeah
yeah you know honor Kona I really don't
you know I don't pay attention to things
I know well I love getting your take
do you think the debates had any impact
at all we had to watch so many debates
do you think it had any impact on the
election no I think you of people
already made up their mind like I was
dying laughing by the fourth one I was
just like who are these people sitting
there in the fourth debate going like
well I don't know but well that was a
good point but then again there is that
it's like you knew who you were voting
for no you knew from day one right what
about the angle there was a lot coming
from the Hillary Clinton camp that Trump
is bad for children and they had a lot
of ads that said you know children are
watching this guy oh we all know duck
children five and six years old they're
always tuning into the debates Watergate
like it was unbelievable I was like
three years old taking it in yeah I was
just like wow this guy's gonna get
impeached I can't this is the most
amazing thing that happened it might
bring it so as a child you were not that
interested in politics and you don't
think children are in general I I don't
I know there's so much stuff that's
gonna it's a really weird time I just
hope people stop yelling at each other
and there's a bunch of just a crazy
stuff out there they're saying that you
know racist white people voted for Trump
and you know maybe some people did but I
also I just think my experience being on
the road is a lot of white people like
like racism like it doesn't track with
them because it's not in their life
right right so it's like it's like our
clothes you know you just love this can
I afford this is anybody gonna make fun
of me if I wear this you don't think
about the person who like sews it
together for like a month for a dollar
right and wants to jump out the window
you know yeah so that's how people look
at it so cuz I noticed like when I was
on the road I'd be like you know this
guy's got people yell on the n-word out
at his rallies what about that and like
white people be like yeah well you know
I'm not I'm not about that you know I I
definitely don't condone that but Hilary
will blah blah blah blah and that's what
I learned it's like people give it about
what's gonna like affect them so I don't
know it's not a fun time
[Laughter]
again it's not a lovely having you here
[Laughter]
I don't know yeah I don't know what's
gonna happen I don't think is gonna be
as bad as people are gonna say I hope
that all this screaming and yelling is
gonna stop and you know I hope people
step outside themselves a little I don't
know yeah I think they will take it the
anyway
you